and today three of the workshop on
Natalie Shum I'll be chairing the day
I'm from the University of Manchester
and we started a bit late to start a
little later to our morning break we'll
be in five minutes shorter we do want to
keep on time because of the streaming so
our first speaker is the John Greenwood
for Brown University practical message
to reduce privacy loss with disclosed in
statistics based on small samples well
thank you so much it's really a pleasure
to be here I'm an economist I so I have
never heard of differential privacy up
until about I'd say 15 months ago as we
started working with a particular
project that I'm going to share with you
today we were working with the US Census
Bureau and it became very clear that we
needed to apply techniques that came
from this literature but for reasons
that I will discuss it like didn't quite
work out to use exactly what comes
straight out of the literature and so
what we did is we work with the Census
to try to find you know a kind of a
practical method to kind of apply
something that was in the spirit of what
a lot of you have worked on and we think
it's pretty close although as I'll be
clear about what we ended up doing is
not formally private and I think that
this type of collaboration is a really
good start if we want practical
researchers using these types of tools
on a regular basis and I'll kind of talk
a little bit as I go along about you
know where exactly I think the holes are
but you know I've already received you
know so much useful help from so little
and from Cynthia and from Coby and for
many others so I really appreciate that
and I look forward to continuing the
collaboration so let me first just kind
of set up what the problem is that we
want to think about in a general way so
economists and other social scientists
are increasingly using administrative
confidential data not just for large
national statistics but to publish
statistics based on cells with a
relatively small number
observations so you know a couple of
examples people think about school
quality and you want to know like is
this a good school or a bad school you
can think about hospital quality in a
very similar way so that's kind of
institution specific similarly people
might want to think about small areas
you want to think about health outcomes
mortality or upward mobility that's what
we're going to think about today so in
our particular application we are
interested in intergenerational mobility
and the basic structure of the statistic
we want to construct is shown by this
graph this is a national graph this is
real data and what we're doing is and I
kind of I will describe all of this in a
little bit more detail at the end of the
talk but we are finding kids in
administrative data and we're linking
them to their parents and what we're
asking is relative to what their parents
earned how much do the kids earn and you
know I'll explain the scaling later on
but you see that there's an upward slope
here each dot is basically the
conditional expectation of kids earnings
based on a particular level of parent
earnings so you see this upward slope
that means that kids from richer
families tend to do better as adults I
think that's not surprising but what's
interesting is the extent to which both
the level and the slope of this
relationship changes as you look within
the United States
so think about one particular statistic
that you might want to look at so let's
just take the predicted value of kids
income born to parents that are at about
the 25th percentile so that's at about
$27,000 so on average in the US kids
born to parents who earn $27,000 grow up
to themselves earn about at the 41st
percentile which is about 31,000 $32,000
and so one thing that you might be
interested in doing just to take this
simple statistic and ask how does this
vary across places in the US or across
demographic groups and so again I'll
show you much more about this later
here's a national map of what that looks
like the blue areas are there's a heat
map so blue areas are better you can see
scale down here and then I've picked out
a couple of of cities you see it varies
from as high as 46,000 in Dubuque in the
Upper Midwest to as low as 27,000 in
Atlantis so we're seeing you know kind
of enormous variations across the u.s.
and the problem that we want to focus on
is generating this statistic at a really
local level right why do we want it at a
local level because you know when I'm
meeting with the mayor of Atlanta and we
say you know gee your city doesn't have
very good upward mobility she's gonna
say well you know tell me what I can do
about it and if all we have to say is
well kind of be more like Dubuque that
is not very helpful and what would be
much better is that if we could look
inside Atlanta and figure out whether
like fine on average there's not great
mobility but are there places within
atlanta where there are very high
mobility neighborhoods or low mobility
neighborhoods we might be able to
understand kind of in the context of
atlanta what seems to be working what
doesn't and maybe that would help lead
to policy just something is is this
adjusted because what you're showing now
is talking about average income so what
I see from this is average incomes in
the Upper Midwest have gone up a lot
that average incomes in the south of
gone down yeah so it turns out that the
actual economic growth has been exactly
the reverse places like Atlanta have
seen enormous economic growth yet kids
who grow up in poor families that are
still do very badly whereas in most
places in the Upper Midwest there's
actually been very slow economic growth
or average income growth there's a good
weave I'm happy to talk about kind of
some of the details behind it but this
turns out not to be driven by like cost
of living or economic growth or anything
like that this you could this turns out
to be very these national patterns
they're not to be very robust to that so
if we want to do this at a local level
we're talking about census tracts in
particular we're gonna start to have
very small samples and we're gonna need
to treat privacy very seriously so what
we're going to do is we're going to draw
on the large literature around noise and
fusion methods and you know essentially
we're going to find that the
testing methods kind of don't really
work for the type of thing that we want
to do which in particular is a predicted
value from a regression I'll talk a
little bit more about this in a second
and so we're going to develop this
method of doing this which we call the
maximum observed sensitivity algorithm
and what we're gonna find I think that's
key is that it seems to provide
reasonable levels of privacy protection
despite the lacking of a formal
guarantee but also it has very nice
statistical properties in the sense that
you can still have quite a bit of
statistical precision and you can
actually eliminate statistical bias with
respect to some of them work commonly
use traditional kind of accounts based
suppression that have been used in the
literature so we kind of the big picture
is that we think that something like
this is you know has a real potential
for people who want to do social science
research and you know really love your
comments as I go through this about kind
of how we can make this even better and
how we can kind of close what what are
still the remaining holes that you'll
see so I'm gonna talk about go through
this in three steps first I'm gonna talk
about what our method is in kind of a
simplified setting then I'll give the
application I'll go a little bit more
into detail of exactly what we did both
from a research perspective and from the
privacy algorithm perspective and then
I'll compare with traditional methods so
so just to formally state the problem we
want to release these predicted values
from univariate regressions in small
cells and so again just to be very
straightforward think about a linear
regression think about a variable that's
bounded between 0 and 1 you can think
about that as the income rank and the
outcome variable is also bounded between
0 and 1 and all we just want is the
predicted value at the 25th percentile
here so in this case it's you know about
you know point to one this is a fake
data by the way so we're gonna follow
kind of the Laplace mechanism where we
add random noise and you know as many
people in this room have studied right
you can achieve this formal bound when
you add noise with the scaling parameter
of the sensitivity over Epsilon so let
me not dwell on this here because
everyone you know is familiar with it
but I think you know the key remaining
question is how do we calculate this
sensitivity that is appropriate for our
setting and the problem here is that the
standard approaches are not going to
work so just to give you a few examples
the first thing we thought up would be
to try something like just measuring the
global sensitivity or smooth sensitivity
and the problem is these things are
going to be infinite in a regression
setting so why is it infinite just to
give you a very simple example suppose
that we started with data that looked
like this so that the predicted value is
like super super negative red you can
make a kind of arbitrarily negative and
then you add one point up here the
regression line snaps up to this dashed
line and suddenly now the predicted
value is something that's finite so you
can construct these examples and you
know get the sensitivity to be
arbitrarily high what's unsatisfying
about this of course it can be the case
that you know a single point can you
know infinitely impact a predicted value
of a Russian you know probably that you
know the world does not look like this
it doesn't look anywhere close to like
this and so the intuition behind what
eventually we're gonna do is we're gonna
try to restrict the space in some way to
kind of rule out this type of perverse
case and find something that is the
largest sensitivity that we see kind of
in a more reasonable range of the data
so a couple of other things we thought
about there's been a lot of work around
more robust regression techniques things
like mediator regression or other
techniques I think the problem here
these techniques are very unpopular in
the social science literature more
generally and I think the reason is that
the downstream properties of these
estimates are not that great so just a
simple example if I give you a bunch of
medians or conditional medians you can't
then iterate them up to get the median
of the medians in the way that you can
do to get the mean of the means and so
again think about practically in our
example if we were to output estimates
for lots of different census tracts you
cannot then aggregate them together and
get an estimate for say a city in the
way that you can with
means and so that's gonna be why we
ended up not going with these types of
estimates another approach that we
thought about would be to compose the
regression estimates from the individual
moments so you could take the ratio of
the covariance and the variance to get
the the slope and then you know
similarly estimate the constant and then
get at the predicted value from that way
those statistics do not have infinite
sensitivity and so you'd be fine from
that perspective the problem is that
these tend to be biased statistics and
then even when they are in practice not
that biased you end up having a ratio of
one noisy thing to another noisy thing
and so when you get the noisy thing in
the denominator you get just get very
very unstable estimates and in practice
it's not really that usable
so what do we do what we're gonna do is
kind of search across all the cells in
the data to calculate the maximum
observed local sensitivity so in in our
particular example the cells I think map
very naturally to these Geographic units
of tracks so let me just think it's
easier to show in a picture so suppose
that all of our cells had exactly 50
observations each in them so what we can
do is just calculate the sensitivity for
all of them and then you'd find this
point up here was the maximum observed
sensitivity in tracks with 50 people now
in practice our tracks have lots of
different numbers of people in them so
you can't just take the straight max
so what we're gonna do is now just plot
all of the dots so these are now all of
the sensitivities that we observe across
all of the tracks and we're gonna take
the upper envelope to this set which is
going to be scaled with 1 over N because
that's the scaling for regression
coefficient you know you could scale it
with some other rate for another
statistic and so what we're gonna get
here is the whole thing now is going to
boil down to this single parameter which
we call Chi which is the hypothetical
sensitivity maximum sensitivity if you
only had a single observation in the
data set or to put another way the the
envelope is just going to be this chi
divided by n and so I think that
in practice this is going to do is it's
gonna going to rule out all of these
quite perverse cases where you know we
really don't see these things in the
data and it's gonna provide kind of a
local estimate and you know another way
of thinking about it is it's very
similar to empirical Bayes as a
statistical technique where you know in
a straight Bayesian application there's
a prior and you just like the priors
whatever you think about the world you
just impose the prior in an empirical
based application you use the data to
estimate the prior to kind of give
yourself a guide as to like roughly
where you think you should be and that's
kind of a similar setting here we're
gonna use the data to let it be our
guide for you know what is the
reasonable range in some sense for the
data in any given cell to give us a
sense of where sensitivity might be and
so in this particular case it's pinned
down by that point there which is
tracked with about a hundred and twenty
observations but you know in any given
application it may come out differently
so then what are we going to do we're
gonna run forward with the noise
infusion mechanism where we're just
using this hyper ammeter divided by the
number of observations in each cell as
the the scaling parameter along with
epsilon and then in order to be able to
understand in the release data how much
noise has been added you have to release
Chi you have to release epsilon and then
you also have to tell people how many
observations are in a given cell and so
we'll do a noisy a noisy version of that
as well so the method is not provably
private right because we use the data in
order to estimate Chi and so kind of in
in concept you know that all of the same
problems that could occur from directly
using local sensitivity occur in kind of
a diluted way because we're using the
maximum of all the local sensitivities
and so we want to be very clear about
that
but I think what's very nice about this
is that we've reduced the problem so
that it now instead of worrying about
the privacy loss from a statistic that's
coming out at the level of attract we're
worried about the privacy loss from this
Chi statistic which is coming out at the
level of some much larger aggregation
and so in practice I'll tell you later
what we were
do is use state by race by gender cell
so think about like all Hispanic women
in California would be a cell and so you
know sometimes it's gonna get smaller
but it's still over pretty large groups
of people in a way that at least
intuitively feels a lot less risky than
releasing this type of thing at the at
the track level and so you know okay so
how do we actually use this so let me
tell you a little bit more about exactly
where the data are coming from so the
data for this approach that this project
come from a merger between census data
and federal income tax records that have
been linked together and merged within
the US Census Bureau and then they strip
all the identifiers off so we have a
de-identified linking of these datasets
and what's very nice about this is that
the census data provides a lot of very
useful kind of nuanced information at
relatively low frequency whereas the tax
data provide relatively high frequency
information on what's going on so you
can kind of use the census information
to understand like what race people are
or what the household structure is but
then you can follow them forward in the
in the tax data to see what the kids are
earning in each given year even if
they're not actually in the census data
so we linked kids to parents based on
dependent claiming in tax returns and
we're gonna target children who are born
in this six cohort block here this is
kind of like the Goldilocks cohorts they
are kids are old enough so that we
observe them in our data today at an age
where they're kind of in the midst of
their earning careers and it's and it's
quite interesting if the kids are too
young then they're still in college or
grad school you don't get a good measure
the kids are young enough though that we
can still observe them living with their
parents at the very beginning of our
sample if we had kids that were older we
would lose the parent linkage and so
this is kind of a nice match in the
middle that's available with current
data we're gonna restrict to children
who were born in the US or are
authorized immigrants because we
basically cannot track the parents when
they're living abroad and
that gives us an analysis sample of
about 20 million kids and we think that
relative to the target sample we're
getting about 96 percent of individuals
kind of check this in various ways we
measure incomes so first we measure
parents using adjusted gross income so
this includes all of the different
income sources wage earnings capital
income anything like that and we do it
in an early period from 1994 to 2000 and
what's really nice here because we
basically observe the population if you
don't file we basically know you didn't
earn very much it's not literally true
that you are nothing but you can
actually go find these people in other
data and verify that their earnings are
like a couple thousand dollars at most
the kids we measure using pre-tax
incomes measured kind of as close to
present as we can get it which is in
2014 and 2015 the kids our age is 31
through 37 in those years so you should
think of this is you know they're really
kind of right in the middle of their
working lifetime partly in order to
mitigate life cycle bias the fact that
people just earn more as they get older
and also it turns out to be very helpful
with the privacy rather than looking at
incomes in dollars we're gonna look at
incomes measured in percentile ranks so
how do we do that
first we rank kids relative to all other
kids from their same birth cohort so
like I was born in 1980 my income would
be ranked relative to all other kids
born in 1980 whether they're working or
not in the country then my parents will
be ranked relative to all other parents
with kids in the 1980 cohort so think of
that as some measure of relative to
other kids in my own cohort did I grow
up in a family that had more or fewer
resources in the distribution and then
there turn out to be quite important
nonlinearities in certain contexts so
let me just show you an example of this
this is the national plot we have parent
income on the x-axis and these ranks
I've given you the dollar cut-offs to
give you a sense and then on the y-axis
instead of using income here we're
looking at the fraction of individuals
that are incarcerated
and each dot is just a fraction of men
who are incarcerated we're focusing on
black men here if the fraction who were
incarcerated on the day of the census in
2010 April 1st 2010 and so I mean first
of all just as a social science point
note that 20% of black men are
incarcerated from the poorest families
on this day not in their lives not over
the course of the year but they're
literally in jail on this day from the
statistical perspective you see there's
this kind of quite important on
linearity where you know it's negatively
sloped as you would expect but then
there's this kick up where kids from
poor families at the very bottom are
kind of disproportionately likely to be
incarcerated and so in order to capture
this in the data it turns out to be
quite important what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take this national slope
this national function and then we're
gonna transform the parent ranks and so
that's what this afford that's what this
F function is so rather than just having
the raw parent rank you transform it
with this and what that has it what it
basically does is it stretches the
parent rank distribution so that you
know 0 and 20 are gonna be further apart
in practice than 60 and 80 just because
you know that's what matters
and so we're it does end up being a
linear regression but off of a bunch of
transformed variables the final thing is
that in practice many children move
across tracks I've been talking about
tracks just as though there were totally
separate buckets and so what we do is we
wait kids in each regression by the
fraction of their childhood that is up
to age 23 that we observe them living in
this track and so there's a little bit
of overlap from place to place although
in practice there's actually much less
movement than you would expect or you
might okay so now let me turn to the
privacy method kind of how did we
particular implement this MOS method so
the first thing is we wanted to make
sure we could get the full line or I'm
in this case the full kind of nonlinear
line and so what we did is we produce
predicted values at both the 25th and
75th percentiles of parent income
separately what we then found is that in
certain tracks predicting say the 25th
percentile is a little bit weird because
there are no kids or parents living in
that tract that are anywhere close to
the twenty-fifth percentile so the
classical example is think about
something like Princeton New Jersey it
just like makes no sense to think about
what would a kid who is very poor living
in Princeton New Jersey end up earning
as an adult because that person does not
exist so what we did is we instead
predict the median and then either the
first or the hundredth percentile for
tracks with either less than or more
than 20% of obscene 1/2 the distribution
so that's probably not so clear so just
to give one example if you were sorry so
these I actually spent quite a bit of
time with this so in practice what we do
is the thing is broken into discrete 100
discrete bins and so it's it's it's 1
and 50 or 50 and a hundred but it's
there's no max in there I think
cleaner way to do it would have just
been to use the function and then just
plug in 0.5 and 1 but it turns out that
from a implementation perspective that
was more complicated so right so if if
you have a place like Princeton where
fewer than 10% of habla de de one would
imagine are living with below the median
of the national income then we predict
15 100 and if you have the reverse
circumstance so suppose you know there's
some very poor tract saying like
inner-city Newark we would predict the
1st and the 50th and so you know this is
one place where there's a kind of a
little bit of extra privacy leakage
would be better to have been doing this
on publicly available data but this is
the what we ended up having to do second
we winds arise the data this turned out
to be very important both from a
statistical perspective and from a
privacy perspective we Windsor eyes the
data so that is we take values in any
given tract that are outside the 5th and
95th percentile and we bring them in to
the
95th percentile so in general this is
important to reduce just the sensitivity
of the estimates but also it is very
helpful in reducing the the sensitivity
in a privacy perspective and what's very
important here is that we estimated the
sensitivity and this maximum observed
sensitive the envelope on the composed
function including the Windsor ization
and then the regression and and so you
know when you're adding a point to you
know test the sensitivity you know you
have to then again do the Windsor
ization after that so third we define
the cells as I mentioned for this
scaling parameter at the state by race
by gender level that basically was done
to comply with the current census
guidelines on this fourth we were forced
to exclude very small cells to comply
with current IRS regulations so IRS
doesn't let you publish statistics if
there are fewer than 20 individuals in a
Cell so we we didn't do that here again
there's a little bit of privacy leakage
because it would have been better to
censor on the public counts so then you
wouldn't you know there's like a little
bit of extra information being released
but then the problem is if you censor on
the public counts then you might not
sense or something because the public
count is 20 but in practice it's less
than 20 and now you violated IRS rules
so such as the world
so finally rather than using laplacian
noise we used gaussian noise the reason
why we did this is that in practice
gaussian noise is is again much nicer to
downstream estimation so you can do
things like Bayesian shrinkage
estimators or construction of confidence
intervals in a little bit of a cleaner
way and so when you do this with a
normal you just have to plug in the same
parameter and then multiply by root two
in order to get the standard deviation
to be the same the normal still has less
fat tail so you're not quite gonna
satisfy the privacy bounds in the tails
but again I think we're kind of
reasonably close in practice we then set
the risk tolerance Epsilon
following John a vowed and the annuities
work and what that does is basically
trades off the privacy benefits of an
hire sort of a lower epsilon with the
social benefits of more precise data and
in our particular context we define
social benefit in two
different ways one which i think is
pretty straightforward was a mean square
error loss metric the second I think
this actually turns out to be more
important it's the accuracy of
information when predicting the best and
worst tracks so why would you care about
this so consider a family who's looking
at these data and trying to think about
where to move right what you don't want
is to have someplace that looks like
it's a really good track but in turns in
fact turns out to be terrible and so we
constructed statistics like what is the
distribution of the truth conditional on
in the public data it looking like a
really good track being like the top 5%
top 10% something like that and again
this is more than just hypothetical we
are actually doing a randomized control
trial in Seattle in cooperation with
their Housing Authority which basically
does this it provides information and a
little bit of assistance to help
families move to high opportunity areas
and you don't want to be telling people
to move places and then it turns out
because of the noise you've added it's
it's not a great place yes yes I mean I
think I would worry about it from I
think I both worry about devaluing
neighborhood and properly we also worry
about there a lot of Mayors who want to
focus on revitalizing very low
opportunity places and they're - we
don't want to like have them go all
gung-ho into a neighborhood and then it
turns out to really not be that bad and
there's some other places that are much
lower opportunity that that they could
have been directing their effort to so
we calculated I mean in practice what we
do is we calculated a bunch of these
percentiles we bast like what's the you
know what's the 25th percentile of the
distribution in private of the tracks
that look really good in public and then
we kind of used that as the as a metric
for this for this calculation is
question the more challenging way that
she avoided sure did you think about
accounting for the protection from false
discovery that
noise that was infused gave you so what
do you mean the false wine using privacy
protected estimates yes
protect yourself from false discover you
saying that was alone
oh oh I see like oh sure like yeah so we
did not think about that week I mean
week we could I mean it turns out that I
think that there are many other ways in
which there's still a little bit of a
gap so for instance one particular thing
is that you know these are all
historical estimates let me just show
you you could actually tell the clients
that because there's protection against
false discovery there's a better chance
that a similar analysis repeated yes
similarly structured data would come to
similar conclusions rather than
necessarily relying on realized yeah
that's a good point and I'll talk about
statistical reliability in in a moment
so let me show you what this all
generated and this is sorry oh for
governor
yeah I mean I get I don't this is an
example we like produced a bunch of
Statistics and produced a bunch of these
curves and we kind of eyeball they
didn't proposed something it was not we
didn't want to tie ourselves too
specifically to one particular you know
we did this 4.95 we did it for point
nine point nine point eight point seven
five similarly you know you can ask
what's the 5th percentile of the real
distribution what's the twenty-fifth
percentile just to give a sense wait
this was all kind of I think this was a
very useful framework to think about the
trade-offs but in practice it wasn't
like the answer was the output of a
formula was more like here's where
things seem to here's where things seem
to flatten and so it's kind of not worth
pushing beyond that so let me show you
like what this generates so here's this
map I showed you before this is a
website called the opportunity Alice org
which is publicly available so again
this is the national map and what's
really nice because of what we were able
to do here we can now zoom into places
like Berkeley so we're we're sitting
about here right now and you can see
this you know the the colors here are
the same as I showed you on the national
scale so the blue right blue is like
high outcomes like Dubuque and red as
low outcomes like Atlanta except if you
know Berkeley these are all within like
a mile of each other
and this is something that we see in
almost all cities across the country
very large amounts of variety between
neighborhoods that are very close
together more generally you also see
that while the intergenerational
mobility from these neighborhoods is
correlated with things like how
expensive is it to live there and how
rich are the people it's far from
perfectly correlated and so you end up
finding some places which are actually
relatively low rent so places that are
like down here is kind of a good example
these places are relatively low rent and
yet they're kind of much higher opportu
than places that are over here and so
for instance when we work with the
housing authorities that's where they're
interested in so they can help direct
people to places that are affordable but
are still kind of relatively high
opportunity this website has been viewed
by more than half a million unique users
in the past six months since we released
it at the beginning of October I guess
five months and you know this is like
actually becoming a pretty useful tool
for mayors or housing authorities other
people who are thinking about the
geography of opportunity for kids in the
US and you know this is something that
you just would not have been possible
had we not been able to draw from the
tools that helped develop so in the
interest of time let me go back and talk
about how we compared this with
traditional methods so I think there are
three key metrics that we were
interested in first what the privacy
losses second statistical bias and third
statistical precision and you know first
from a privacy loss perspective here I
think it's more just conceptually that
you clearly get much more in a more
consistent way in a more precise way
using this type of noise infusion
technique than using things like cell
suppression and so you know in our
particular example kind of the
uncontrolled privacy loss is just this
single thing for a given cell and we're
protecting all different sizes it's not
that you know we're protecting for small
cells but then if you happen to get two
adjacent large cells then then you're
out of luck so you know here I think
this was quite important now what you
might worry about is that infusing noise
it's kind of obvious that'll have these
benefits but are you going to lose
something from the perspective of either
precision or bias and so what we were
quite happy to find is it actually it
seems to help on both fronts so in terms
of bias what we did is we compared our
noise infusion approach to account based
suppression approach and what's very
particular here is that once you infuse
noise right you know exactly what you've
done and so you can back it out of the
data quite easily whereas with count
suppression approaches it's often very
difficult to back out some uncorrupted
estimate you get bias that shows up in
very subtle ways so let me give you an
example here this is an actual statistic
that we put in the paper
we want to know our teenage birth rates
for girls growing up in poor families
higher for those who grow up in a
neighborhood with a larger share of
single parents right so if it's only mom
around in most cases does that lead
girls and poor households to be more
likely to become teenage parents so here
is what you get in the noise and fuse
data you get a slope that's highly
significant and positive it makes sense
if the share of single parents in your
neighborhood goes say from 10 percent up
to something like 50 percent the
probability that girl growing up to poor
parents ends up as a teenage mom goes up
from say 34 percent to 40 percent so
it's you know reason of it's like a 15
percent increase if you had done this
instead in the count suppressed data you
would have gotten that which is not just
quantitatively a much much flatter slope
but it's now no longer statistically
significant so what's going on here
what's happening is that I think this is
the easiest way to show it if you focus
on the number of people in these cells
with teenage births right mechanically
places that have very few people who end
up becoming teenage moms are gonna have
a much smaller numerator which these
council brush and methods are more
likely to need you to suppress and then
what's more so it turns out there's so
there's the numerator suppression part
of it then there's also a denominator
suppression issue which is that in
places that are smaller that is have
fewer I'm looking at black women here
have fewer black women teenage birth
rates are also much lower why is that
because these women are living in much
more integrated typically wealthier
neighborhoods and so they're just very
different than folks who are over here
the problem is that you're basically
chopping off all of these folks and so
what you're left with is only a set of
folks so let me just go back here right
why is this so flat it's because you're
missing all the data down here right
they're a bunch of black women who live
in low single parent share places who
don't end up
having teen births and they're being
suppressed from the data and the only
people that are left over is either if
you have a lot of teenage birth in one
of these low single parents sure places
or you're in a high single share parent
place in which case most everyone is
left so that ends up with this bias you
know again I think you know ex-post it's
we can understand where this is coming
from but like I don't know how one would
ever have tried to back this out like if
all I had showed you was this how you
would ever get back to the correct
answer in account suppression world is
so it generates these kind of quite
subtle biases from a precision
perspective to what we find is that the
the noise infusion is really not so bad
so if you take here's just one simple
way to think about it if you take the
total variance of our estimates you can
then decompose that into three
components that add up there's the
signal variance that's the actual
underlying variation in upward mobility
from place to place
there's the sampling noise variance
that's the extent to which because we
have small samples we kind of happen to
get a higher or a lower estimate just in
the finite sample that we drew and then
there's the added privacy noise variance
that comes from the noise infusion now
the size of this obviously that's going
to be controlled by epsilon and so that
could be larger or smaller depending on
like whatever threshold you chose the
point here is that even if epsilon had
been quite a bit larger you're still
really not you know you're still like on
the order of magnitude of the standard
error and so to the extent that you're
producing estimates they're gonna be
largely affected by this you basically
already have a big problem from sampling
noise and so in some sense like if the
things weren't gonna work out great for
you anyway even if you didn't have the
privacy noise and so my sense is in most
applications that people are going to be
interested in if you can get the
sampling noise down to a reasonable
level then the privacy noise really at
whatever level of epsilon is not going
to be so much of a problem and so it
kind of in practice I think there's like
less precision trade-off than you might
worry about because most of the
precision losses are coming in places
where things are really very imprecise
to begin with and I think that's a
function of the fact that this stuff
scales with
with n whereas this stuff is scaling
with root end right so when the numbers
get big this is going to go away and
when the numbers get really small this
is going to grow faster than this but
this is already growing in a way that's
going to cause problems for you in the
first place and so my sense is that you
know you're still going to have a
problem with estimates from you know
cell sizes of ten or something like that
but kind of in the range where we are
which is kind of 50 to 200 this for the
most part works out pretty well so yes
please
obviously that would scale with Epsilon
that's right that's right two different
ways of thinking about the accuracy
materially affect how are you that's
right that's right yeah so just to kind
of restate what john said he's exactly
right so you're gonna I talked about
these two definitions of social benefit
the graph I just showed you is like a
mean squared error loss metric so you
turn out to do you do pretty well on
this front just from a from a precision
perspective the reason is that it's this
one that that bites most when deciding
in that's what we found in practice in
our procedure that bites most when
determining the level of epsilon and so
I think you could have gone to kind of
you know 1/2 or 1/4 the level of epsilon
and and not had that much of an effect
here it was really here where you you
really start to lose precision in these
in these tale outcomes that's exactly I
think that the sampling variability as
well as the disclosure avoidance
variability had been a part of the
criterion that this issue about whether
the inferences were correct in the tails
is even more affected by the sampling
period though
then by the we bench we benchmarked at
that though what we did is we saw right
there's kind of three different
calculations you can do
where's our two different calculations
you do one is suppose that you have no
noise infusion but you have sampling
variation what will the distribution of
true values look like for the public top
five percent and right because that's
not gonna be only the top five percent
because you've got the sampling variance
in there then there's additional losses
beyond that and what we did is we
benchmarked to the no privacy noise but
empirical sampling variation level of it
so that we kind of that's like the the
one on the social banner
it's the incremental change exactly
influence the privacy loss budget if you
had instead added them together to say
it's it's the overall inference that we
want to have a high quality not just the
yeah that would have justified a larger
smaller I could go to either direction
depending on but I agree with you that
the curves would have looked different
we are yes we are in agreement done yes
yes yes so we I know we're basically out
of time I would love to kind of talk
with you all more about this throughout
the rest of the week but I think that
there are kind of two main lessons that
I took away where places where I think
that you know the the literature you
know kind of where from a very high
level is the literature not quite
reaching practice and so I think that
there are two two things so the first of
all is this is this this is basically
just about that Chi right so we're
releasing this Chi it's at this high
level of aggregation but itself is not
formally private if we all have this
intuition that it's like much better in
a not it's not formally private in a
better way than some things that are not
formally private in a worse way but at
least we weren't unable to think about
like a formal way to make that statement
and so figuring out a way to have
privacy loss not be something that's
either like one or zero but some
kind of middle-ground to give a sense of
like what are better or worse ways to
get almost there I think would be very
useful the second thing which I think we
realized more at the end of this but
which i think is very very important
from the perspective of practical use
right in practice if you want people to
use this thing
what its gonna have to be is like a
totally automated thing that somebody
likes sticks onto the end of a routine
whatever it whatever it is they're doing
and so if somebody's running a
univariate regression if somebody's
running multivariate regression if
somebody's running like a differences in
differences regression if somebody is
using some instrumental variables
technique there's like all sorts of
stuff that people do there's gonna have
to be kind of like one thing that works
across a very broad set of estimators if
people have to redesign the algorithm
every time they come up with a new
statistical approach I mean like
conceptually obviously that's like a
very nice and elegant thing to do but
like in practice that's just gonna be
way too much work for people and they're
not gonna want to do it so I think one
advantage of this algorithm that we came
up with is that you know like you can
kind of you can adjust it as you go to
different settings but the thing is
really very flexible in the sense that
if we have been using a much much more
complicated regression estimate you
still could have just done this thing
where you iterate through you calculate
the sensitivity in each of these cells
and then you get this envelope that
basically would have worked for almost
anything you want to do whereas my sense
is that a lot of the other techniques in
the literature are like much much more
method specific in a way that I think
makes it harder for Applied researchers
to use and so I think developing these
kind of quite flexible techniques is a
important piece of of turning this into
practice thank you all so much
time for more questions I have to catch
down during the break